I showed you the golden rectangle and I
said look people will think
yeah that's pretty beautiful if you go
and look up you know pictures like the
Parthenon ancient architecture and like
from old times or even really modern
things you like yeah okay golden
rectangles they're appearing everywhere
we looked at the golden spiral where do
we see it going spiral shells right um
galaxies and you can find other places
what which I'd like you to do later
today where is this puppy Turner well if
we just do like you see the back one you
don't need to do all those yeah just do
one and those two will leave okay yeah
okay so we're gonna have to give me a
hand how's the exposure it's super
bright super dark is it okay good all
right so to show you how incredible the
golden angle is just like every other
golden thing that's out there right
first you need to learn a little bit of
botany okay so Bonnie's not studying
plants yeah now here's a bunch of
flowers okay now the only critical piece
of information you really need node want
a new wise is what if flower grows you
can always see it right can you see
there's a whole bunch of little cells in
here in the actual center of the flower
in between the petals um what I need to
know is that a flower grows from the
inside out okay from the inside top if
you see if I might even zoom in a little
bit you will see like look these cells
are small they've just been born as a
work and then what happens they migrate
outward
as they do they grow they get older and
they get bigger okay so they start from
here in the middle outwards okay now
what a flower wants to do is it wants to
be as all creatures want to be as
efficient as possible with like this
space that it's got because you know
nutrients I was going to say nutrients
don't grow on trees but um well they
plant anyhow
nutrients iron limited supply right so
we want to use as least of them as
possible to create as much of this as we
can okay so they're going to spurt out
these new cells kind of like in a
circular formation and they'll rotate
around and send these cells are at
different angles to fill up this kind of
circular shape and here's the way they
do it
what they're doing is starting from the
center okay and then they will go
through some kind of rotation and send
out a new cell then the new cells will
start hearing from migrate outwards so
let me give you a really really simple
example here we go start with here now
imagine for me before I pledged to go
and you see it happens it's gonna send
out itself it's gonna rotate halfway
around the circle and send out another
cell then it's gonna rotate another half
way around and it's gonna set up another
cell and on and on and on now what do
you predict will happen before I say go
you're gonna give a straight line aren't
you uh in some ways you're going to get
two straight lines one going this way
and one going that way because it keeps
rotating so let's have a look okay fair
enough and you can kind of make out like
you've got the really really small cells
here and the big ones here because they
grow out further make sense okay what if
I did a quarter turn right what if I did
you would do fine well it's going to
send a sell out quarter turn sell out a
quarter turn so you're going to get a
cross aren't you this makes sense you
can see the way that what you with me so
far okay
No
now unfortunately a couple fraction see
maybe four for them without put in this
what do you predict will happen this is
like a third isn't it's pretty close
it's not exact it's a third right now
when I did a half we got two lines when
they did a quarter we got one two three
four lines this is a third so what do
you predict three lights right okay now
in a second right I'm gonna put any
number in okay I could do I could do a
fifth and you would rightly predict that
how many hours would you get if I didn't
point to up here you would expect five
what are you okay now I'm not gonna put
that in because that's too easy I'm
gonna put in point four instead what's
point four is a fraction as two fifths
pause for a second don't say anything
what do you predict will happen it's not
a fear it's two fifths so are you ready
here we go
hold on a second it wasn't a fifth it
was two theaters but I still got what
you probably predicted for a fifth right
why is that why is that hmm
yeah how are you wants to give a
suggestion because
very good let me repeat that last phrase
again because so crucial and I'll say it
another way even though like it's - fits
not a fifth right because two and five
don't they're not gonna factor with each
other eventually you're gonna hit all
five those spots here's the way to work
if there was point to it would go one
two three four five right just one time
one fifth bit of time because two fits
instead of going from here to here
you'll just jump over to here but
doesn't matter because it'll go one two
three four five it's still gonna get to
all the same spot just gets into a
slightly different make sense okay now
so far we've been doing some nice neat
fractions okay but watch what happens if
for instance there's something like this
now I'm going to pause and I'm not gonna
keep going yet what do you predict will
happen what do you expect for a half we
got um half to four quarter we've got
formal arms for a fit etc hmm not
predict in your hand now a couple of
things are interesting here right
shout out something that you observe
they're not straight anymore are they
before they were exactly straight now
they are not straight right what else
the observe it's a spiral because
they're not straight okay what else do
you observe
I have count up one two three four five
six seven arms now I wonder if you can
think about why there would be seven and
there are meant to be seven okay number
one why are they no longer straight okay
well let's go back a result that would
be straight would be something like a
point-to-point you that's right in fact
all of them if they're 1 v 2 v reaches
45 5/5 will not like this that's not
let's just concern about this way
but all of them are giving you these
five okay but if I do something else
like say point seven what you said
straight or curved straight how many
there are 10 why is it 10 it's seven
tenths isn't it okay so why do these
give me straight lines in fact if I have
you know harsh or quarters or fits
straight but for some like forty three
I'm not getting them straight the
difference is noticeable so it's like
okay yeah okay so so it's something to
do in how far you're rotating each time
okay now this is great right this is so
cool because this is do you not agree
this is math we're doing maths right now
right but this is not the kind of
message is to you it's like what just
just tell me the answer okay but that
would stop us doing the actual math okay
let me tell you why it's spiraling this
number doesn't fit neatly into one 360
degrees if you like there's no
combination of 0.43 you can keep up on
top of itself so that you eventually
come round to the same spot okay now let
me come back to zero point
okay the reason why you get straight
lines here is because once you've done
four quarter turns you are exactly
exactly back where you started
right and if you did 1/5 five turns will
take you there and if you have a sixth
six turns of take you there right but if
you do a number like that what would one
I just gave you
this is interesting there's more arms
but they're still spiral are they not
because no matter how many lots of 0.23
you do you'll never get back to one do
you see that you'll go 0.23 point four
six point six nine point nine two and
then the next one will be one point one
four I've shot past one and then you
keep going around you still won't come
back right and you'll have to do 100 of
them before you come back so you're
getting the spiral but here's the thing
right right if you might be blind if
you've got Basham numbers in here you
are always gonna get either straight
lines or spirals okay
but this look out here it's so
inefficient somehow without doing any
maths no gaps no gaps how did it do it
right ah now before I do it
okay what I want is I said the problem
was with rational numbers okay
rational numbers are gonna give you like
if it's over seven you'll get seven arms
okay if it's over you'll get eight arms
and so on okay what is something that's
not rational right not rational okay now
what's a famous irrational number pick
me a famous pie right sure okay now I
know I could do more that's um that's
plenty
okay now I'm going to for a second in a
second I'm gonna ignore the three can
you tell me why I can ignore the 3
because 3 goes one two three actually
has no effect by any whole number of
revolutions two disappeared okay so I'm
just gonna make a zero point okay all
right now predict predict what do you
think will happen
mmm you ready
you're like well number one they're not
straight that's a plus okay but they're
also well not very efficient I like how
many ARMs 7-7 arms why this seven arms
because as you might know pi right
pi happens to be very very close to this
number three point one four to eight
free memory okay which is why we use 22
over 7 as an approximation it's not it's
not equal but it's close enough to three
decimal places pi is close to well this
part of pi is close to just a seventh so
you get seven arms so even though this
is an irrational number sorry that's not
rational
even though this is an irrational number
it happens to be very very close to this
rational number so you get it kind of
behaving like what does that make sense
so what we want is a number this is
really really irrational right and the
more irrational it is the more dense
everything's gonna be right now
all I think that's pretty amazing okay
yeah now what was this um what was this
topic like we're looking to go on ratio
now what's the topic Beauty and
mathematics do you not agree that that
is beautiful right if you don't if you
look at this and you don't think that's
beautiful
I true story you know in the in Berlin
Paris in the Louvre right there's the
moon early size hanging up on the wall
okay and yeah someone comes along and
says the Middle East is there it's very
old who says that this is a really good
piece of art like that's up to
interpretation isn't it like what if
what if some people say that's rubbish
there's a god they're standing there
next to the Mona Lisa because there
always has to be right and since you
know the time is ended for this piece of
art to be judged now it is the viewers
who are judged does that make sense
think about it right if you come to
something like this and you think and I
think that's beautiful it says more
about us as viewers than it does about
this I think that's beautiful and that's
what the golden ratio is about